the first trailer for Avengers infinity
war has already provided Marvel fans a
ton of clues about what's to come in the
newest superhero smash featuring the old
guard and the newcomers working together
to defeat Thanos but there are some
aspects of the teaser that might not be
so obvious upon first review let's take
a look at some of the finer details in
infinity Wars first trailer that might
hold more significance than you think
the hero hotline when Tony Stark has
shown visiting doctor strangers sanctum
sanctorum there's an interesting little
easter egg contained in his hands the
same cell phone that Steve Rogers gave
him at the tail end of Civil War even
though the two didn't completely resolve
their differences
Steve apologized for withholding the
truth about Bucky's assassination of
Tony's parents in a note that also read
I know you were only doing what you
believe in and that's all any of us can
do it's all any of us should so no
matter what I promise you if you need us
if you need me I'll be there cat maybe
enjoying asylum in Wakanda but it's
clear Tony's going to take him up on the
offer in Avengers infinity war once the
threats of Thanos becomes clear new
shield in the trailer to charla the
black panther instructs gets the Spanish
shoot he's talking of course about
getting Steve Rogers back into superhero
action and the lion also serves as a
clever callback to the characters comics
history in 1941 the captain earned the
trust of two challahs father to Chaka
who gave him a piece of wakandan
vibranium which was then used to help
form cap circular shield decades later
when Rogers gave up the title of Captain
America in a dispute with the US
government he was gifted a new vibranium
shield by black panther now a nomad
Steve isn't the only one sporting a new
appearance and the trailer there's also
a subtle difference on the way Bucky is
outfitted as the star looks to be
missing from his new Bionic arm since it
was lasered off of him by Tony Stark in
the same battle that cost copy his
shield
Bucky too might have decided to shed a
piece of his pre Civil War identity and
go forward as a non Winter Soldier Nomad
has he read his mind of all that pesky
Hydra programming at long last Sebastian
Stan has cast doubt on how well that
would work out for him telling The Daily
Beast
I think Bucky represents some of those
people that come back and just don't
know how to restart their lives
a new vision in the first new glimpse we
get a vision in infinity war he looks a
lot more human than he used to his
appearance is almost ordinary save for
the bright yellow stone embedded in his
forehead in the comics at a finding
feature of Jarvis's post download
existence is that he wants to be as
human as possible so the fact that he's
now been able to shed all the red at
least for a while means that either
someone's fantasizing about what might
have been
or he's figured out some way to
shape-shift into his desired reality in
either case he's clearly developed a
romantic relationship with the Scarlet
Witch which is also a nod to a central
component of his comics origins the two
had quite a storied relationship
throughout the years often tumultuous
but also resulting in twins named Wiccan
and Speed who both end up on the younger
vengers team during their teenage years
a certain casting call for Avengers 4
seems to indicate that the latter part
at least will come to fruition blondes
have more fun
Natasha Romanoff is another of the
exiled Avengers who seem sporting a new
look in infinity wars first glimpse
rather than the dark auburn
dude that's been her trademark all these
years she's shown with blonde locks
she's probably still a fugitive at the
start of this movie and the humor
Verdoux may just be a simple effort to
disguise herself from the government
however some suspect it might also
harken back to the comics second the
Black Widow character Yelena Bulava who
sported similarly blonde locks if she is
just trying on a new identity for size
why not make it her alter ego one
plucked from the page as a hot tip to a
comic fans frozen in time although we
don't know for sure if Thanos has or
will be able to steal the time stone
from the sanctum sanctorum there's at
least one shot in the trailer which
hints that time is being messed with in
some way as Tony Stark has shown on the
streets removing his glasses and
disbelief the rest of his friends seem
to be left in a frozen state behind him
what's more is that those mystical
shields seem to be turning very slowly
if at all does this mean that Thanos
will get his hands on that powerful
green gem despite the hero's best
efforts aura Starks somehow commanding
the time gem in the scene
time will tell Nick Fury the storyteller
although we don't actually seem in the
trailer we do get to hear Nick Fury's
voice chimed in on the group
storytelling project that tells us how
the event just
to be there was an idea he's joined by
other characters to finish out the
narrative but his inclusion is important
because the phrase is an almost exact
replica of the speech he gave in the
first Avengers movie samuel l.jackson
has said he will not appear in infinity
war Avengers 4 or black panther but
could this be a sign that something's
changed if not at least we know fury
will be there in spirit thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to